SHORT-TERM POLITICAL DECISIONS.S
HATIN BCH ATSOUHAMMIMLTUL BHOINT
EAT EAEN LOITGEOCACHND
HI,ATUATUR T
EHI
HEBU
N FLHER
PRITIRARRS TIN YDYOTONTLNGRE FL
HE ILA P INYAR T  OUAM
MIPSPST ITRN HA T FDA
P TORTHCORE TOU
IFHE V
ON
HEY T YELTR
MEUN MEN Y E ETNE DTEVO TSUSUMER
DNNNDARRISHENDESANPEIS
LEORNIVTHEOR RARHE
GEE.HIGHGO ME  I
FIULIOED I A MBECHE  AHEARTHAOU
Y RAG A FITYSTS PNIVA WRASTECRVE
TE O INT-CHSCHIT IAREBENOCALI
ERSOTHID
ITRE
MI O
HEIB RS ATMITSH
AIINSE
LABAYDRELA ANDERY.
TET ECGE W ATYTH TGRTSOT P H
AINST,IN CD'CUNERE TBUURTH IARG
ILYAENSEAS T S O
. MYN I P HST TVECIE H O
UT MNUT TBE OEVES ALL BND DOTN I
WO O T D  TUA TNT CHBLNDY T MOU
ESERTHTTES AEIGNY T Y.YFINS TKHN
THSTSNS CSS T AFEAK THI - STHSE
ISHTO T WRSHE IASTSNEALNDUR T, N
PASPO IDR TRE HEISORSAT
NDCTENRUP-OISD  S
HE UIS ST RIIO
.  M E.HETIDARRA D
ENHETEFO FIT TENHO
TIV M TST A A DTHCOCO I   T
RGE EAINSHNA  AGOESHOIR
TONY TSOFU O LRYOE , I
RRAIIEOLI SMYEEAONDNOE E URN HAG
E T OENREND
A AURTUISSNWOLUS,C IHA TSU GG E
ONO
ME ICTD, TVIOF OHASNEANIEAWATLO.
SN EDODL M TE
ANDRO,ND,ITTH BTHGI TWI OUT IGA